Speaker 1: Hey, this is very, very strange. There
is a new report that radical Trumpist Republican
Congressman Matt Gaetz under investigation
for a number of different potential crimes,
including trafficking of a minor across state
lines for sexual purposes. We have a report
now that Matt Gaetz sought a Trump pardon before
before the Trump riots. This is this is strange
because it raises the question of why did
he want that pardon? Newsweek report says
Florida Republican Congressman Matt Gaetz had been
personally pushing for a broad presidential pardon
from Donald Trump before and after the January
6th attack. The House committee investigating
the riot revealed one of the biggest revelations
from Thursday's hearing was the testimony naming
six Republicans, including Gates and others
who wanted clemency from Trump before he left
office. By the way, that includes Louie Gohmert
and Marjorie Taylor GREENE. Additionally, Alabama
Representative Mo Brooks allegedly, allegedly
sent an email on January 11th seeking, quote, all
purpose pardons for every lawmaker who objected
to electoral votes from Arizona and Pennsylvania.
Gates has been contacted for comment. The
other gates part. In her recorded testimony,
it was described how Gates had been asking
for a presidential pardon before the other
Republican lawmakers accused of being involved
in attempts to overturn the 2020 election.
Quote, Gates was personally pushing for a pardon
and he was doing so since early December. I'm not
sure why, said Hutchinson. He reached out to me
to ask if he could have a meeting with Meadows
about receiving a presidential pardon.
Eric Hirschman, a Trump White House lawyer,
also said in testimony played on Thursday. Gates
wanted a wide reaching pardon from Trump. Quote,
The general tone was we may get prosecuted because
we were defensive of the president's position
on these things. The pardon he was discussing
requesting was as broad as you could describe
from the beginning of time up until today for
any and all things he mentioned Nixon and I
said Nixon's pardon was never nearly that broad.
This is very strange. So the natural question is,
why did Matt Gates so early and so broadly want a
preemptive blanket pardon? The natural speculation
is, was Gates trying to crowbar in a preemptive
pardon for the things he's being investigated for
personally? Well, it's merely speculation, but
it's a reasonable question to ask. The issue is
most of the stuff. Let me
I'll put it a different way.
Many of the things Gates is being investigated
for are state crimes and not federal crimes. And
a presidential pardon wouldn't help you with
state crimes. That being said, the interstate
trafficking of minors, that's a federal crime and
that's a really big deal. So one speculation is
Gates figured, you know, everybody's going to
try to get pardons and we're going to say it's
for supporting Trump's view about the election and
trying to fix it and all these different things.
But maybe I can sneak in some help with what
I may be up against criminally for my personal
activities. That's one possibility. It is amazing
that we regularly are charging, regularly and
quickly charging all sorts of different people,
poor people, nonwhite people, people not in
positions of power for insignificant, oftentimes
kind of contrived charges. The war on drugs,
you could argue, is contrived at the big
picture, as we know the origins of it
to be a sort of racist reaction to the Civil
Rights Act of the 1960s. And then meanwhile,
Gates and his fellow, whatever can be suspected
of having committed pretty serious crimes.
And they just walk around. They often never even
get charged. And when they do, it's all done
very respectfully to their image and to their
PR. Even when there is, in the case of Gates,
corroborating witnesses, corroborating witnesses
who are cooperating, as we know. Jared Greenberg,
I think, is the guy's name and the example of
Gates. So, you know, Trump likes to talk about two
justice systems, the one for right wingers and the
one for everybody else. It's a completely bogus
framing of the entire issue. We do have two
justice systems in the United States. I've talked
about it for a long time. It's people in positions
of power and who have money and who have influence
and then everybody else. And we are definitely
seeing that with Trump and his cronies and the
people around him and maybe also with Matt Gates.
The reason for Gates wanting this preemptive
blanket pardon? We can speculate. Maybe at some
point we will know. But it's a real question mark.